Byron Donald's just continued yesterday
he had an All-Star day he went on the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC and not only did he go there he
went in right into the office with the
chief crazy lady he went to Joy Reed and
they talked about everything so we're
going to show you a whole bunch of Clips
here and just watch just watch this
master class in professionalism
knowledge Candor decency communication
the whole freaking thing that Byron
Donalds puts on and then compare that to
how Joy Reed behaves as a host so I want
to start by just talking about in the
previous uh segment with Congressman
swalwell we were just talking about the
changes
um that are happening in the house under
this new leadership three people
including Congressman swalwell ilhan
Omar and Adam Schiff have been take are
being taken off their committees
those who are being added Congressman
Santos is the one who made up his whole
resume allegedly in New York Paul gosar
whose family have said he's a white
supremacist you know attended sort of
meetings of white supremacy and got
kicked off his committees because he
tweeted out an anime of killing
depicting him killing AOC uh
congresswoman Alexandra Kaiser Cortez
and Marjorie green they're getting back
on committees I just wonder what you
think of that do you think that that is
a good look for the Republican party no
I think going back on committees is what
should happen look well we told Democrat
leadership when they went down this this
pathway of removing members from
committee is basically saying you should
not do that because if it's good for the
goose it's good for the gander let's be
very clear Elon Omar has said things
that are reprehensible hold on hold on
hold on let me finish she has said
terrible things about about the Jewish
community so much so that resolutions
had to go to the house floor about them
and they were watered down with respect
to Eric swalwell and to the other
gentlemen that's something for speaker
McCarthy to speak to in more detail
because he's going to make those
decisions but we were very clear in the
117th Congress we should not be going
down this pathway of saying oh that
member said this they got to be kicked
off of committees that is happening no
no no no no we're not what we're doing
is she said you did it so now this is
what happens this is the response let's
get back to the status quo of you pick
your committee people we'll pick ours
and we'll go from there well let me ask
you this because that isn't you're not
getting back to that status quo if
you're kicking people off committees and
you're saying it's literally for
vengeance you're now admitting it's just
for Revenge that doesn't sound like
getting back to the status quo it sounds
like using committee leadership
you want to change the rules and we'll
live by your rules I don't think we
should do that but if you want to change
the rules that the House of
Representatives has lived Thunder since
the beginning of the Republic and now
you're going to change them because you
didn't like what somebody said I don't
think that's a change in the rules
that's happened before he knows exactly
what he's talking about and he's got
receipts and it's true when they started
doing this a couple years ago when
Democrats started saying we're going to
kick certain Republicans off committees
because we don't like this thing they
said or that thing they said everyone
was saying it I'm sure you can find
videos of us talking about it on the
show right like everyone was saying once
you start this Tit for Tat thing Goose
skander this is exactly what's going to
happen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]